con y pondrá a partir de este viernes
pulseras de geolocalización a los
consejeros que cumplen cuarentena
domiciliaria para controlar sus
movimientos también adoptará el código
de colores que ya funciona en la china
del interior de forma que una persona
tendrá el color rojo en su móvil si está
infectada o amarillo si está en contacto
con algún infectado en el último caso
tampoco podrá visitar lugares
especialmente sensibles como hospitales
o residencias de ancianos las medidas
han generado cierto escepticismo en
parte de la población de las pulseras se
critica su falta de exactitud ya que
tienen un rango de error de entre 50 y
100 metros del código color stm que
pueda desincentivar a muchos que
comuniquen su contagio para no ver
limitado su movimiento y en ambos casos
los sectores antigubernamentales
critican que se haya adoptado políticas
de la china del interior que si tienen
cierto aroma pero no son las mismas en
la china del interior por ejemplo a los
contagiados se les prohíbe la cuarentena
domiciliaria y son enviados quieran o no
a un centro de internamiento hong kong
ha adoptado la política de cero
en el interior pero en cuestión de
eficacia están en las antípodas un
millón de hong kong es es de entre una
población de 7,5 millones se ha
contagiado han muerto nueve mil personas
en lo que va de año y en esta semana se
rozan los tres mil casos diarios es por
eso que la excolonia ha tenido que
recurrir a algo parecido a la receta del
interior